for the past few months most of the
leaks and rumors have been pointing to
apple's imac pro coming at their spring
event in just a couple of months but
unfortunately we just got some horrible
news from ross young who is one of the
most reliable sources out there so what
i'm gonna do in this video is analyze
ross's disappointing leak and give you
guys three different scenarios for what
can actually happen with this year's
imac pro launch as well as a potential
consumer friendly 27 27-inch imac at a
lower price which might actually get
released sooner than the imac pro but
before i get into all of that we gotta
go through these recent leaks so you can
fully understand the situation with
apple's upcoming imac pro last year the
reliable dillon dkt on twitter was the
first source to mention that apple's
imac would be getting delayed until 2022
and then after that ross young actually
came out and claimed that the new imac
pro would come with a 27-inch display
size in the first quarter of 2022 which
would likely mean a spring event at the
end of march which i've already made a
full video on so definitely check it out
but then out of nowhere dylan dkt came
out with a huge leak claiming that the
new imac pro could come with a
mysterious 12 core chip built for high
performance but the downside was that he
was hearing that there were some
production issues that might lead to it
getting delayed potentially as late as
september in the worst case scenario and
just this morning ross young finally
confirmed that the imac pro is not
coming at apple spring event being
delayed until this summer with a
potential launch in either august or
september which actually matches what
dylan said now unfortunately dylan has
recently announced that he is retiring
from the apple league scene so we won't
be able to get any further updates from
him but i think i trust ross in terms of
the imac pro delay leak so if it's true
that the imac pro isn't coming until
summer or even later then what does this
mean for the regular 27-inch high-end
imac because as we know the current
intel imac starts at 1800
and the old imac pro used to start at 5
000
so if there is only going to be one
high-end imac pro coming out later this
year with a high starting price of
around four thousand dollars or higher
then there would be a massive price gap
between the 24 inch m1 imac for thirteen
hundred dollars and this new very
expensive imac pro and because of this i
think apple absolutely needs to have a
27 inch imac at a starting price of
around 1800 or 2 000
no matter what so what i'm gonna do in
this video is try to make sense of all
the different ways we could still have a
consumer friendly lower priced 27 inch
imac while also getting an additional
very high end imac pro and in my opinion
there are three main scenarios for how
apple can make this happen so let's go
through all of them for the first
scenario i can see apple completely
renaming the larger 27-inch imac as the
new imac pro so that it's more simple
and easy to understand and differentiate
between the smaller 24-inch imac for
consumers and the larger imac pro for
pros so they would essentially reveal
just a single imac pro later on this
summer and it would start at around two
thousand dollars and come with
essentially the same m1 pro chip as you
get on the 16 inch macbook pro but then
for the upgrade options you'll of course
get to choose the m1 max and then most
likely a new higher end chip like either
the m1 max duo like we've been talking
about for a while
which would include apple taking two m1
max dies and combining them together
using the secret die to die interconnect
that they conveniently left out of their
marketing images or on the other hand it
could actually come with the new
mysterious 12 core chip that dylan
leaked last week and those upgrades
would get very expensive probably around
four or five thousand dollars before
even going crazy on upgrading the ram
and storage so in this scenario instead
of the past when apple had both a
27-inch imac and a 27-inch imac pro
they could both be built into one
machine just with a very wide range of
pricing and this could actually make
sense the reason for that is because
mark german believes there's a good
chance that apple could reveal the apple
silicon mac pro at this year's wwdc in
june just so that they can say that they
finished the two-year transition on time
and this idea makes sense because wwdc
was actually when they revealed the
previous mac pro and they just delayed
the launch until december now in my mind
this could actually make a ton of sense
because the mac pro is expected to come
with both the m1 max duo chip and the m1
max quadro so i can see them revealing
those chips and then announcing that the
new imac pro will come with up to a 20
core m1 max duo but if you want the 40
core quadro you've got to go with the
mac pro and this would also make it a
little bit easier in terms of marketing
those chips meant for the most demanding
workloads out there but now let's move
on to the second scenario and this one
is actually quite similar to the first
but with a small little tweak what if
instead of apple just releasing one imac
pro in the summer with a wide range of
chip options there's actually going to
be two separate products revealed at
different price points a regular 27 inch
imac and then an imac pro just like it
was in the past so the 27 inch imac
would come with an m1 pro chip up to the
same m1 max configuration available in
the new macbook pros and then if you
wanted a more powerful chip you'd have
to go with the imac pro with either that
new 12 core chip or the m1 max duo and
the reason it makes sense to split them
up into two products is because it'll be
more clear and easy for people to
understand the price points with apple
giving a certain starting price for the
imac pro and if you think about it the
previous imac pro was known to be very
expensive starting at five thousand
dollars so if apple had to combine them
into one imac pro product costing as low
as two thousand dollars it would lose
that high-end premium professional feel
and then on top of that it would be very
difficult to know how much performance a
certain imac pro has just by looking at
it for example you'd have no idea if
someone's imac pro was the two thousand
dollar base model or a very expensive
five thousand dollar plus model with an
m1 max duo and this could cause some
confusion so this scenario would
basically mean that later on this summer
apple would reveal both a 27-ish imac
and an imac pro but now we have the
third scenario which is by far my
favorite so let's get right into it when
ross young tweeted about the imac pro
delay i decided to ask him if there's a
chance that there could be a regular
27-inch imac launching this spring and
then an imac pro later and he replied by
saying that he's not sure because
they're only tracking the one imac pro
product so because of this there's still
a good chance that we could get both
products not just one and if you think
about it this makes the most sense
because it would allow apple to fill the
price gap between the 24-inch imac and
the imac pro with a regular
consumer-focused 27-inch model starting
at around 1800 or 2 000
which could be revealed at apple's
spring event and if you're doubtful of
that happening it was recently revealed
that the current nano texture display
option on the intel imac now has a
shipping date for the end of march which
is pretty odd unless a new 27-inch imac
actually comes at apple spring event
which i think will be happening in march
and i really think this would make sense
because they'd be able to have a much
more consumer-focused imac with a larger
display and up to an m1 max chip just
like the macbook pros and of course at a
lower price which i think is very
important to apple and then later on in
the summer potentially at wwdc apple
will reveal the new imac pro which comes
with that new 12 core chip that dylan
dkt leaked or straight up to that crazy
20 core m1 max duo and another way they
could differentiate it is by giving the
imac pro a better mini led display with
120hz promotion while the regular
27-inch imac could just get the same old
5k lcd 60hz display as before to help
keep costs down and make the imac pro
seem superior because if you think about
it adding mini led and 120hz promotion
is going to be a lot more expensive on a
27 inch display compared to a smaller 14
or 16 inch like on the macbook pros and
if you don't believe that apple would
release two 27-inch imac models just a
few months apart apple actually did this
in 2017 with both a regular 5k model and
an imac pro around half a year later now
as far as the design it would
essentially have the same 27 inch
display size with the same chin but the
regular model could come in more
consumer friendly colors like the 24
inch imac and maybe even white bezels
just so that it matches the smaller
model in their marketing images like it
always has in the past and then the
27-inch imac pro will probably have a
slightly thicker design for a much
beefier cooling system like we currently
have on the intel imac pro and then of
course black bezels and a space gray
color which could remain exclusive to
the imac pro model and i really hope
that this third scenario is what apple
goes with because we'd be able to get
the new 27-inch imac as soon as the
spring event without having to wait
until potentially september now if you
totally disagree with me then go ahead
and let me know your comments down below
but if you enjoyed the video click that
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and definitely
check out one of those two right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next one
[Music]